[Musique]
si le prix nobel de la paix iranien ne
peut éliminer l'injustice au moins elle
la raconte à tous
dans son livre la cage dorée elle écrit
l'histoire vraie d'une famille ravagée
par les idéologies et nous donne les
clés de la révolte iranienne
la colère ne peut être qu exacerber
lorsque dans un pays la liberté
d'expression est décrié
bayonnais
c'est ce qui arriva javad un des
personnages du livre
décharné en java d' se retrouve
emprisonnée puis exécutés tout
simplement parce qu'il a exprimé une
opinion
les colères de shirin ebadi première
femme à être nommée juge en iran trouve
son origine dans l'injustice
shirin est né il ya 63 ans dans une
famille de classe moyenne où la notion
d'égalité était une valeur phare tu
avais un meilleur round route mon père
était juriste s'est donc finalement
grâce à lui que j'ai poursuivi cette
vocation et que je ressens un tel amour
pour la justice c'est hors baie c'est un
homme qui croyait profondément l'égalité
des droits il a toujours considéré les
êtres comme égaux et c'est avec cette
valeur que j'ai grande dame qui est un
centre en parlera à ça pourtant il ya 30
ans lors de la révolution shirin ebadi
descendait dans la rue pour soutenir la
république islamiste seulement au
lendemain de la victoire de khomeiny
elle se voit dépossédé de sa charge de
magistrate les eye est là ont décrété
que les femmes sont trop émotive pour
diriger un tribunal et rabih
évidemment mon identité en a été bafouée
d'avis dans un pays où la loi stipule
que le témoignage d'une femme a deux
fois moins de valeur que le témoignage
d'un an et agacés
biot
est ce que vous savez ce que cela
signifie
c'est un meurtre est commis dans mon
cabinet et que j'en suis le témoin ma
déclaration ne sera pas acceptée on n'en
prendra pas on
ne nous fera pas confiance or si l'homme
que j'emploie pour faire le ménage dans
mon cabinet témoigner on lui accorderait
à deux fois plus de crédit que moi qui
suis juriste qui était juge et kg et 40
ans d'expérience à la normale d'alma
sont mal vus
chez mme ebadi et la justice vis et au
corps depuis 30 ans elle dénoncé
lapidation les crucifixions et les
exécutions d'enfants son courage lui
vaut le prix nobel de la paix et aussi
de la prison dans son pays biker
en iran à partir du moment où vous êtes
arrêté pour une inculpation d'ordre
politique vous êtes forcément mis en
isolement
et mme savard des makes alors
va j'ai moi-même passé du temps
à
cette torture blanche cette torture
psychologique que je décris dans le
livre je les ai vécus il nommera sa mort
aux cons ambassade à shirin ebadi n'est
pas la seule femme à lutter contre le
régime lors des manifestations les
femmes étaient bien en première ligne au
risque de se faire tuer comme neda morte
devant une caméra est devenu depuis une
icône pour shirin ebadi les femmes sont
l'avenir de l'iran
cela est lié à notre culture ancestrale
il ya deux mille ans l'iran était
gouverné par une femme une impératrice
aujourd'hui la société iranienne compte
de nombreuses femmes parmi son ami tu
es sahel ont toujours eu des rôles très
importants dans l'histoire de ce pays et
si on regarde l'avenir les certain que
les femmes en serons une figure
principale
aucun mouvement ne peut réussir en iran
sans l'adhésion des femmes
depuis la réélection contestée
d'ahmadinejad shirin ebadi est
contrainte à l'exil une situation
insupportable pour elle en trente ans de
lutte cette femme n'a jamais voulu
quitter son pays aujourd'hui deux
colloques en interviews shirin ebadi vit
dans les avions mais cet exil luz
si je parviens à trouver un moment de
répit dans mon travail ce sera pour
dormir je suis épuisé
[Musique]